[Applause]
she is married to Gramps and welcomes
losers and Champs first lady in home
health care Aiden Chief Jill Biden was
at the American Airlines Center in
Dallas Sunday night when the LSU Women's
Basketball team won the National
Championship not to worry Joe was safely
Tethered to a tree in the Rose Garden
but then on Monday things got things got
really interesting when Jill suggested
that both the winners and the losers
should get an invite to the White House
roll tape
so congratulations to both teams so I
know we'll have the Champions come to
um to the White House we always do so
you know we'll have LSU come but you
know what I'm going to tell Joe I think
Iowa should come too because they played
such a good game
[Laughter]
come on Jill the White House is no place
for ladies who finish second
oh
yeah but look at it on the bright side
at least none of the women's Champs is a
dude
for her part Dr Jill did end up walking
back the idea but I guess in the woke
liberal world of the bidens everyone's a
winner
[Music]
we are our champions my friend
and everyone gets a participation trophy
in the end
[Music]
of Champions
[Applause]
[Music]
good
champion
I'm Gonna Hurt
now Kat I'm gonna go right in with you
on this yeah is it a little fascinating
that Jill will invite two entire women's
basketball teams but she won't invite
one Hunter stripper baby
oh
yeah I did it anyway I did I went right
there go ahead that was important to you
it wasn't matter I
oh I would actually be super mad if I
was on either team right because you're
telling them like oh you played a good
game too that's so patronizing when I
don't do a good job at something I know
it and when any when I'm complaining
about how I hate myself and I wish I
didn't blow it and I suck let me just
let me just do that don't be like oh no
you you did a great try like I'm an
adult woman and these are all adult
women uh so don't pretend like oh you
still played a great game well they
wanted the game that would be the one
where they won yeah yeah
and they didn't have that so you're not
making them feel any better no I think
it's insulting but let me build on this
Morgan is it possible
she's actually doing this to help Joe
and prepare him for losing in 2024.
if he even runs he hasn't announced that
he's running yet I kind of agree with
cat like the participation trophy thing
my dad never let me get away with some
of your kids we played softball and my
twin sister and I were really bad at it
and if we like did poorly or we lost he
was like yeah you guys sucked
so like maybe that explains a lot about
me now I also am wondering if there's
anyone in this Administration that
doesn't ramble incoherently when they
speak on the national stage like
somebody's got to have it together it is
a mess but your dad was better than mine
when we lost in Little League he was
like I lost money on this
call yourself a t-ball team
[Laughter]
guy do you expect better than this
though from a highly educated doctor
like Jill Biden yeah
medical doctor yeah
I think the only people who would want
Iowa to be at the White House for that
ceremony less than LSU
is Iowa I don't think they would want to
be there it would be humiliating to have
a pet on the head as the runners up and
we're all winners here they would never
do that with men in men's sports that's
so true because they've never done it
and so I think Iowa wants no part of it
and if the Iowa Hawkeyes want to
guarantee that they are not invited to
the Biden White House they should claim
the game was rigged and that they're the
actual champions
no chance
that's Iowa and Coach Carrie lake is
there you telling me Carrie we love you
uh is this secretly Joe Biden's doing
because he wants two heads of women's
hair to snip
I think you're all being really unfair
here because you're talking like Iowa
was the losers but Iowa identifies as
the winners of the tournament and so
they they have every right to be there
Jimmy you need to be more inclusive
shame on you come on cat where would you
rather go right now honestly the White
House or Waffle House
oh I mean I'd get more attention if I
went to the White House probably but
where would I have a better time
probably Waffle House probably Waffle
House well if we went to the White House
we'd get more attention from security
yeah you know what I mean we went to
Waffle House we get you know attention
from our fans our people you know but as
a sports Guy this is the part that I
keep coming back to okay you're a sports
fan I'm a sports fan we are cheapening
the value of personal responsibility
when we erode Merit from Sports because
kids learn Merit through that crushing
sense of defeat so if you take it away
from them then it's not a Wonder they'll
grow up to want their student loans
forgiven or anything else don't you
think so it yeah like earning something
is the best way to feel good about
yourself people want to make a
contribution if you come up second and
somebody says well that's just as good
as you are so why don't you come to the
White House what are you going to walk
away feeling like I'm a second place
kind of person I think guy nailed it it
would be like calling Jimmy Kimmel the
king of late night right
it's just not right
just not right just pandering spot on
because if we're being honest Jimmy
Kimmel has become the Prince Harry of
late night you know hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else